you said only five only five people have
beaten the devil I almost did it but I
quarterback friend that's what had
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
that's nice
[Music]
that will be
hey what was that the helpline
oh yeah
[Music]
this
it's a lot quicker pace
bye baby
I'm sporting the mechanical attention so
I got five
right yeah I got is this here good right
here
come on yeah you get an AI I think it's
true is it three player coop for two
players so the coop is it's four players
you're going to have three three
individual people that can play and then
one a I depart okay I'm going
let's do it what a money sure
yeah y'all finally you finally got here
[Music]
though
Oh
do
this is crazy
how are you
Bernard
that's right
what do not like though go to our
stylist
enemies
I do
now with that
all day
I can't fight like that I can't I got it
yeah
oh my gosh there was one dude out
playing his game
I'm sorry I gotta fight in this one sir
this people I don't want to play 13
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
this crazy 81:5
I'm just going to stay behind
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh there was nothing I could do
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah
Naama [ __ ]
we're gonna do it go bill
Oh
see that
the popular fiction
when
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
this is some of them you can
[Music]
this games really built on the fact that
you stagger easy so if you think is
Provost a sacrament this wife will
punishing the blood walk
No
I think that
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I don't use them
okay I appreciate mr. Hillman I don't
care
[Music]
I mean they got people back
reminding my
I can't do that man
[Music]
[Music]
but to kill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]
Oh
we gave it a value Network whatever
fantastic games thank you very much the
timeframe will release the games coming
out in 2018 we don't have cold beans in
a business cosine law radical trotty
gave it about actually we're gonna hold
off because they took the camera down I
guess they're doing something like panty
shots the large all means they get sued
that's what's the matter
it kind of Xbox in the building Colby
looks real y'all tell y'all right now
it was a great pal region
[Music]